thank you
Sovereign
as a servant to the Muslim Community
because of him we have been able to
raise
one million dollars
[Music]
and now we're going to raise even more
look at this man right behind me since
we've contract we've got this guy now
now you're gonna have to donate for the
Masjid and the Dao Center in Norway now
as you can see these guys are trying to
move they're getting so angry but we
have shown without a shadow of a doubt
that they have no intellectual leg to
stand on we've also shown that the
Muslim Community now must take these as
opportunities to raise funds we've
already raised for this man help the
fundraiser of the month please take a
look at him everyone give the fundraiser
Clap
[Music]
[Applause]
the fundraise of the month one million
now I tell you what he's we're going to
use them again our mascot our
cheerleader our cash cow we're gonna
milk you for all you've got yes
yes you heard what she said that she
said donate now and she said no no so
you click on that link below and she
what's your name darling it doesn't
matter what your name is
okay so you're going to go ahead and
donate and we're going to go for another
million you know why because Scandinavia
needs it the Muslim Community needs
institutions these people the more they
shout the more we respond and more
response
donate now